but meantime the White House says it
will soon reach a decision about how to
respond to a chemical attack in Syria
they say was instigated by the
government of Bashar al-assad it will
apparently reach that decision even
though so far we do not have proof that
Assad was behind it of course we'll keep
you posted if the US does intervene in
Syria however it could rapidly put this
country in direct conflict with Russia
which for many years has backed the
Assad regime and unlike Assad Russia has
a vast arsenal of nuclear weapons so
what is likely to happen what should we
be worried about Stephen Cohen is an
editor of the nation a professor
emeritus of Russian Studies at nyu and
princeton one of the most famous
professors of russian studies there is
and he joins us tonight professor thanks
for coming on how worrisome you followed
the relationship between the US and
Russia for decades how worrisome is this
moment more worried than I've ever been
for nearly 50 years of studying and
participating in us-russian relations I
think the situation your generation was
born after the Cuban Missile Crisis but
you were taught in school and were my
children that the Cuban Missile Crisis
of 1962 was the moment when we came
closest ever to nuclear war with Russia
and the learnt lesson was supposed to be
we should never get there again and we
are very close and here's why if Trump
or somebody sends these missiles against
Syria there are Russian soldiers
embedded in almost all Syrian army units
even in dormitories if and this I know
because Moscow has said so if Russians
die if Damascus is attacked the capital
of Syria Russia will retaliate with its
excellent weapons every bit as good as
ours some people say in some regards and
missile technology better Russia will
strike Americans in Syria will die and
we will be where we have never ever ever
been with Russia killing each other
bearing in mind that both nations are
laden with nuclear weapons so I am more
worried than I have
ever been in my life at least since the
Cuban Missile Crisis so US forces have
killed over 200 Russian citizens in
Syria in recent weeks
you heard American officials boasting
about that just the other day is there
some reason to think that helps the
United States what do we benefit in some
way by killing Russians in Syria not
that I can think of any more than
Russians would benefit from killing
Americans anywhere that's always been a
no-no Tucker I mean that's been a no-no
throughout the first 40 year Cold War
why would anybody even think of it but
you've asked a really good question
after that happened we don't know how
many Russians died
the Russians let it pass but they said
if it ever happens again we will
retaliate because those Russians were
killed with American operated missiles
and they have said and by they I mean
all the way up to the Kremlin we will
retaliate and since Americans are still
there Manning those Syrian units that is
why what happened the first time when
the Russians let it pass the killing of
Russians won't happen again let me add
something that may not be known to you
or your viewers it is a deeply held
belief whether they're right or wrong
it's a belief in the Kremlin in the
Russian political class that the United
States our country has waged political
diplomatic economic war against Russia
for at least 10 years and the attitude
in Moscow expressed daily is we've had
enough you could interpret that for what
you want yeah I know I still haven't
totally confused as to how this helps us
in any way at all but I appreciate the
warning
and I think warning screen should be
taken seriously professor thank you for
this